- Okay, so this is possible
one of my favorite questions
I've ever asked.
I heard you drank sheep
poo whiskey in Tasmania,
and I need details.
- (laughs) So Tasmania's a
beautiful, tiny little part
of Australia.
It only has something like
300,000 people live there.
But there's over something
like 60 wine distilleries,
incredible.
Whiskey distilleries, excuse me.
- These are my kind of people.
- Yeah, we met this amazing man
that was brewing this incredible whiskey.
But everything was so resourceful,
the way they wasted nothing.
And so, when I started working with him,
I was shoveling sheep (bleeps).
And it was the sheep (bleeps)
(laughs)
that was literally smokin' the rye
that was starting the
fermentation for the whiskey.
And it's actually called
sheep poo whiskey.
And honestly, these production
was 150 tiny, little bottles.
It was already selling
out before we finished it,
it was that sought after.
- Wow, who knew that sheep poo
could be so lucrative?
(laughs)